[Music]
Ralph breaks the Internet is one of the
funniest movies of the year it's got
jokes for everyone but we bet these ones
made kids laugh out loud more than
adults
hey Disney lovers click subscribe to
keep up with all the latest disney for
one one now let's check out the jokes
that only kids will understand in ralph
breaks the internet burping contest the
video game stoppers is supposed to be an
old time bar but instead of adult
beverages tapper only serves root beer
which is just a sweet type of soda YUM
the whole setup is supposed to mimic how
adults go to get a drink from a bar
after work but there's the whole issue
with vanellope von schweetz being a kid
you can't bring a kid to a bar to make
this joke seem less inappropriate
penelope and ralph have a burping
contest that is definitely not something
that adults do but drinking soda and
belgium louder than your friends is one
of the gross things that kids might do
wiffleball it's a big deal when the
internet gets plugged in at the arcade
at the terminal a sign that says Wi-Fi
pops up above the plug actually
pronounced Wi-Fi browse and Wi-Fi is the
Internet
Ralph's mispronounces Wi-Fi as with E
and then wifey
he says it's either a marriage game or a
wiffle ball game wiffle ball get it
Louisville ball is a game just for kids
it's kind of like baseball but there's a
hostak ball with holes have you ever
played ruffle ball did you pick up on
this joke let us know in the comments
serious Duty Roth takes his job from
bean vanilla peas friend very seriously
when she complains about driving the
same old tracks he creates a new track
for her of course this causes her game
to break but Ralph meant well he tells
vanellope he takes his duty as her hero
very seriously
and she says he roams duty duty do you
get it it sounds like something else way
grosser leave it to a kid to make a
bathroom joke at the worst moment
bathroom humor may not be as funny to
your parents but kids everywhere thought
this joke was hilarious Harry Potter
joke this joke might have slipped by a
lot of people only diehard Harry Potter
fans would catch this subtle reference
when Ralph and vanellope first go to
she knows more at the searchbar broth is
totally thrown off by the auto-populates
knows more begins to suggest things that
start with um and after umbrella he
suggests umbrage Briella
umbrage umami no no as I no doubt
Nordstrom that's the evil Defense
Against the Dark Arts professor from
Harry Potter and the order of the
Phoenix she might be the most hated
character in the whole series did any
powder heads catch this reference it was
pretty quick intuitive internet ralph
may have had trouble with knows more but
Penelope didn't she immediately knew
exactly what to search to find the will
for her game ralph was shocked that she
figured it out so quickly she said it
wasn't very hard because the Internet is
very intuitive we can relate kids tend
to pick up things on the internet a lot
quicker than adults we bet you have had
to explain things to your parents and
grandparents before we can't help it if
we're the digital generation have you
ever had to help an adult to do
something easy on the computer tell us
below buzz tube the most popular video
sharing site and Ralph breaks the
Internet is buzz tube this site is where
yes works and she helps Ralph go viral
over and over we know that all of you
love watching viral videos after all
you're on the biggest video site right
now you probably noticed something about
the name of this fake site it's a
combination of BuzzFeed and YouTube
BuzzFeed is full of viral content and
YouTube is where videos go for success
it sounds like a cool internet name but
real Internet fans will know exactly
what buzz tube means fortnight dances
broth makes a ton of viral videos to get
money for the wheel on eBay he does bad
makeup tutorials and mimics Bob Ross but
one joke is specifically meant for kids
Ralph does the fortnight dances the
dance moves in the most popular video
game have gone viral celebrities all
over the internet have filmed themselves
doing dances like the floss we bet most
adults totally miss this reference but
these videos and the fortnight video
game is all the rage among kids this was
a super relevant internet joke what's
your favorite dance move sound off in
the comments
Disney quizzes have you ever lost hours
of your life to taking Internet quizzes
oh my Disney has a ton of great Disney
themed quizzes but this isn't exactly
where your parents hang out on the
internet when vanellope arrives in oh my
Disney she sees a quiz about which
princess is your Disney best friend
these quizzes are so much fun we could
take the internet quizzes all day this
joke was definitely meant for kids in
the audience do you enjoy taking quizzes
on sites like oh my Disney whoo we sure
do who would your Disney Princess best
friend be Zootopia reference the oh my
Disney scene is full of so many Disney
Easter eggs we could watch Ralph rakes
the Internet a hundred times and still
not see all of them there are Easter
eggs meant for adults with some
old-school Disney references like
Nightmare Before Christmas
but there are some mints for kids when
vanellope runs from the stormtroopers
she bumps into a very modern Disney
character Nick Wilde from Zootopia gets
in her way we love seeing all the new
and old Disney references all in one
place which is your favorite Easter Egg
true love's kiss the Disney Princess
scene is one of the funniest scenes in
the whole movie vanellope ends up in
their dressing room they ask her a bunch
of hilarious questions to prove she is a
princess Penelope is a little shocked by
the facts like all the princesses that
have been cursed and kidnapped but then
they ask her if she's had true love's
kiss
we know adults probably think true
love's kiss is super romantic but
Penelope does not she says it's so gross
this is definitely meant for the young
kids
Penelope just doesn't understand the
appeal of kissing can you blame her box
of bees
adults and kids definitely watch
different types of videos online one of
the most popular types of videos for
kids our unboxing videos kids unbox new
toys and we love to see their reactions
adults just don't seem to understand why
these videos are so fun Ralf combines
two popular trends pranks and unboxing
into one he goes to unboxed a fun game
called pancake milkshake fun set but
when he opens it it's a box of bees this
is what sets him over the top
adults may like the pranks and puns but
unboxing videos are all for kids
do you watch unboxing video
the comments section everyone knows that
the comments section is full of trolls
well at least that is a rule that all
kids and teens know when Ralf ends up in
the comment section of buzz tube he sees
firsthand how main internet trolls can
be cyberbullying is a real problem
especially for kids but yes encourages
him to ignore all the haters it's still
discouraging and it may not be super
funny but this is a good lesson for kids
just ignore the haters and be nice in
the comments instead we're glad the
movie touched on a serious issue like
cyberbullying it can be a real problem
grumpy cats when Ralph and vanellope
first arrived in the Internet there are
a ton of hilarious references that we
bet the adults missed everyone saw the
Twitter birds that were literally
tweeting it was so cute but did you
notice what they were tweeting they were
memes a very famous meme in fact they
were all tweeting everyone's favorite
internet cat grumpy cat
we love grumpy cat he is so cute we've
been a bunch of adults totally miss this
old meme reference some things are just
meant for kids do you have a favorite
internet meme let us know in the
comments snapchat filters the internet
in Ralph's breaks the Internet has a lot
of different areas not only is snapchat
seen but there is a whole different area
for snapchat filters and we all know the
filters are the best part of snapchat
snapchat is mostly meant for teens and
younger adults it just hasn't caught on
with all the older people we've been
adults everywhere missed the snapchat
filter area they even showed the deer
filter we love the flower crown and the
puppy dog and don't forget Face Swap do
you have a favorite filter on the
messaging app it's so much fun dad joke
really dumb jokes are often called dad
jokes and Ralph makes one that really
isn't that funny
when Shane tells him not to be a
stranger he says he couldn't be any
stranger than her she fake laughs and
says it's a good dad joke we know kids
everywhere rolled their eyes at this
joke but we bet dad's loved it and it
was such a cheesy joke Ralph is full of
them but he's funny the rest of the time
so we guess we'll forgive him do your
parents make lame jokes tell us the
lamest in the comments baby Moana this
next reference came at the end of the
movie in the first post-credit scene we
see a little
who has just watched the new movie and
she's a little disappointed about a
scene from the trailers being cut from
the film her mom tells her to play her
game instead but we bet most people
didn't recognize baby Moe she's a recent
Disney Princess
it's baby Moana she's the world's cutest
animated toddler ever we bet a lot of
adults missed this joke but Moana fans
wouldn't
did you recognize baby mode the first
time pancake milkshake the game that
baby Moe is playing in the post-credits
scene may not be a real game but it
still looks so familiar we've had lots
of kids place similar games on their
tablets we can see why Ralph would be
bored but little kids love those games
but let's not talk about what happens to
the poor bunny that was awful Ralph
really should try to avoid other games
it never turns out well what do you
think is the funniest moment from Ralph
breaks the Internet let us know in the
comment section and that's it for the
jokes from Ralph breaks the internet
that only kids will understand be sure
to like this video and click that big
red subscribe button for more
[Music]